european union farm ministers have been
updated on progress in negotiations
between the eu's three main institutions
on the thorny issue of reforming the
common agricultural policy or
cap at their meeting in luxembourg the
ministers were briefed by the eu's irish
presidency
about the results of the first six
trilogue meetings between the council of
ministers
the european parliament and the european
commission
ireland hopes that the institutions can
reach a comprehensive agreement by the
end of june
and the progress i think is good uh the
there's a real willingness to to uh
to discuss um compromises and landing
points if you want to call them that um
of uh final conclusions but there will
be points of difference of course
and we will need in next month's council
meeting and of course the council
meeting in june
to work with the commissioner and work
with the european parliament to try and
find
a common agreement the talks are focused
on the rules governing direct payments
to farmers
the organization of markets in
agricultural products
rural development support and the way
the cap is financed
managed and monitored the cap helps
guarantee good living standards for
farmers and stable
food supplies at fair prices for
consumers it also fosters rural
development and protects the environment
the commission also presented its plan
to the ministers on transitional
measures for next year
as the cap reforms cannot be implemented
before 2015.
details of the plan will be taken
forward by working groups and its hope
they can be finalized in autumn
in fisheries talks the ministers
welcomed the plan by the european
commission to reduce
accidental catches of seabirds in
fishing gear
with the presidency noting that more can
be done without major costs
these incidents many involving the use
of long line and static nets
are threatening some bird populations
more broadly the presidency hopes to
speed up work on fisheries reform
saying that agreement is close on most
of the big changes
following debate on the package between
the council commission and parliament
it would also like to adjust its
negotiating mandate
at the next fisheries council in may